we've had the conversation before about
how there are sort of two justice
systems in our country and there's lots
of models of this right there's the idea
that there's a justice system for the
rich and a justice system for the poor
there's the idea that there's a justice
system for white people and another for
not white people prosecuted convicted
sentenced more harshly for many of the
same crimes particularly a lot of the
crimes that sort of fall under the
umbrella of the war on drugs there's a
justice system for corporations and
another for the little guy right the
Supreme Court for example finding much
more often in favor of corporate
interests than in favor of the
individual and that gets us to this week
you might remember this case from March
where Krystal Mason a black woman in
Texas was sentenced to five years in
prison for accidentally voting illegally
in the 2016 election she was on
probation on probation for a fraud
conviction meaning she was not allowed
to vote she voted and she was found
guilty and sentenced to five years in
prison there's another story from last
year about Rosa Maria Ortega who was
convicted of voting illegally in the
2012 general election and the 2014
Republican runoff in Texas she was
sentenced to eight years in prison and
in comparison remember two justice
systems Tarrant County Justice of the
Peace Russ Casey has pleaded guilty to
effectively rigging his own election he
signed off on signatures that he knew
were fake in order to get on the March
six primary ballot he received five
years probation not prison not Jail
so there's actually multiple angles here
right there's the sort of obvious race
angle which is crystal mason is black
Rosa Maria Ortega's Hispanic and Justice
of the Peace Russ Casey is white I
actually don't think that's the most
relevant sort of judicial system
disparity here the more relevant one is
that crystal Mason and Rosa Maria Ortega
are random people whereas Russ case is a
justice of the peace right he's part of
the system and I read an argument online
saying we'll hold on a second crystal
mason was already on probation when she
voted illegally that means her sentence
should be harsher
we're talking about a justice of the
peace who rigged their own election
that's a proactive action isn't that an
aggravating factor compared to
accidentally voting illegally there's
another argument I read which is well
Mason was a tax preparer years ago and
she inflated some returns for clients
that's a white-collar crime and I'm not
defending white-collar crime in fact
I've argued that white-collar crime is
not prosecuted harshly enough but you've
got to be consistent and crystal Mason
getting five years in prison when a
justice of the peace gets probation also
doesn't make sense and then we get to
the broader problem prosecutor Matt
Smith was asked about the sentencing
disparities and he said well the two
women Rosa Maria Ortega and crystal
Mason they didn't accept plea agreements
and they went to trial
Casey accepted a plea agreement that is
really really disturbing to me because
what the prosecutor is basically saying
is that the women ended up with harsher
sentences because they invoke their
constitutionally protected right to a
trial right and if the job of the
prosecutor is justice punishing people
for invoking their right to trial is
problematic at its base and we know that
that's how it works right we've talked
about the entire plea agreement
industrial complex it's a mechanism used
to put nonviolent drug offenders in
prison in huge numbers and that's
something we should all be concerned
about and then lastly there's the other
debate we've talked about this before
probably a bigger conversation than we
can have now which is should you be able
to vote when you're on probation
and sure to be able to vote when you're
in prison it's a broader debate what was
I remember you took a strong position on
that Pat although I don't remember what
it was oh I don't know I mean I'd have
to think about it a little bit you feel
like maybe once you're when you're in
prison I could see them taking away your
right to vote
you're okay certainly when you're on
probation or parole you should be able
to that's my take the counter argument
would be probation and parole are
privileges you could be in prison the
entire time so that your actions are
evaluated as if you were still in prison
like that's a moment they would make
once you're on probation or parole you
start to get some of your rights back
so I think voting can be one of them in
any case there's like three or four
different layers to this story and the
bottom line is five years probation for
a guy who rigged his own election yeah
and these are really harsh sentences
sentences to like five years in prison
or eight years in prison
yeah and it's no wonder why voter fraud
isn't really that prevalent because
those are really harsh sentences and
it's an exchange for one seemingly
inconsequential vote you're not gonna
change an election with that and so it
argues that three million people voted
illegally it's not very true what we've
seen is that number one very few people
actually do so-called in-person voter
fraud or illegal voting and that when
they do they're often trying to test the
system to prove how easy it is to vote
illegally and they end up getting caught
and being sentenced to prison like it's
the actual exact opposite narrative as
to what you would need to believe to
believe that three to five million
people voted illegally for Hillary
Clinton
we will follow whether there are appeals
here for sure the video you just watched
was made possible by support from you
please go to patreon.com slash david
pakman show you can make a pledge of as
little as one dollar per month and every
dollar helps to support the work that
we're doing particularly in light of the
YouTube ad boycott which has been really
bad